dies ist eine Praxis über die keiner
gerne spricht und nur wenige Armeen
wenden sie an im englischen heißt es
target killing auf Deutsch gezielte
totungen
in Deutschland verboten in Israel
gängige Praxis
[Musik]
alle startet hier also die Sammlung von
Informationen durch den Geheimdienst die
gezielte Tötungen alles passiert in
dieser Militärbasis
ob gezielte Tötungen oder Aufklärung das
Sammeln von Informationen wir starten
und landen immer hier
die Ziele der Tötungen morgen in
Deutschland tabu sein aber sowohl die
israelische Armee als auch die
amerikanische Armee wendet diese Methode
seit Jahren an heute kriegen wir bei
Bild ein exklusiven Einblick wie so eine
Mission aussieht
ein Stützpunkt mitten in Israel
wo dürfen wir nicht sagen ein Einsatz in
den palästinensische Gebieten wird
vorbereitet ich begleite dich
Spezialeinheit als einziger Reporterin
die Jagd auf Terroristen beginnt
Israel wird von einer Terrorwelle
erschüttert
seit Beginn dieses Jahres wurden 14
Israelis bei Terroranschlägen ermordet
und 22 verletzt
sie werden jetzt einen weiteren Anschlag
verhindern
aus 20.000 Fuß haben sie ein
verdächtiges Auto ins Visier genommen
der Tourist ahnt nicht dass er längst
von den Spezialkameras erfasst wurde und
jeden Moment eliminiert werden könnte
soweit uns bekannt ist sitzt in diesem
Fahrzeug ein Attentäter der die Absicht
hat die Siedlung anzugreifen wir werden
eine Rakete abschießen feuern ist
erlaubt sauber zum Angriff die Rakete
ist raus 10 9 8 sieht ganz Schaden am
Fahrzeug vor das Fahrzeug hält an
sieht aus als hätten wir es getroffen
die fahrradtür öffnet sich
er versucht zu fliehen so weit ist uns
betrifft ist es ein sauberer Schuss
[Musik]
kürzlich gab der Chef der israelischen
Armee grünes Licht auch im
Westjordanland gezielte Tötungen
durchzuführen
der Tod kommt aus der Luft Drohnen
bestückt mit Raketen
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten die mit uns
im Aufklärungsflugzeug sind beobachten
die Ziele und geben grünes Licht vor den
Abschluss die Terroristen hören und
sehen nichts
[Musik]
okay wie sie jetzt sehen können haben
wir das Ziel angegriffen vorhin haben
wir hier zwei Leute gesehen die etwas
Weißes trugen wir erkennen hier ein
weißes Objekt außerdem steht hier ein
Container der gerade brennt
[Musik]
so operiert die israelischer Meer seit
Jahren im Gazastreifen nun auch in
weitere palästinensische Gebieten wir
fliegen gerade Ober und wir folgen einem
dunklen Auto wahrscheinlich Blau das
Team hier kann mit dem Kameras alles
sehen wer sie sehen was sie planen und
das Team kann jederzeit entscheiden ob
man sie abschießt oder nicht
[Musik]
man fühlt sich nicht wie in einem
Flugzeug und man kann diesem Fahrzeug
jetzt stundenlang Folgen er kann mit
beliebiger Geschwindigkeit Reisen es
beeinträchtigt uns nicht weil wir so
hoch sind und die Kamera sich jedes Mal
nur sehr wenig bewegen muss
wenn wir die kam
era wenn er Details wir entdecken z.B
dass das Fahrzeug eigentlich bordeaux
ist
die Zielpersonen werden zuvor vom
israelischen Geheimdienst identifiziert
wenn klar ist dass sie einen Anschlag
planen übel nimmt die fliegende
Spezialeinheit
beobachtet die Terroristen notfalls
tagelang aus der Luft
die Terrorwelle steigt und als Staat
Israel wollen wir immer zwei Schritte
voraus sein wir führen seit Wochen
Verhaftungen in Judäa und Samaria durch
und wir haben die Möglichkeit gezielte
Tötungen durchzuführen die Methode
existiert aber wir haben uns entschieden
sie bislang noch nicht zu nutzen
[Musik]
die fliegenden Anti terror-einheiten
führen aber nicht nur tödliche
Luftschläge durch viele
öfter unterstützen sich Spezialkräfte am
Boden helfen Ihnen Terroristen
aufzustöbern und festzunehmen
[Musik]
niemand will aus der Luft töten niemand
will überhaupt jemanden töten wir wollen
die Menschen vor Gericht stellen und als
erste Tat wollen wir die Menschen
verhaften
natürlich ist es unmöglichen Gaza
einzureisen und verhafte und vorzunehmen
also erledigen wir die Dinge aus der
Luft aber wo die Möglichkeit besteht
diese Menschen zu verhaften hat dies
immer oberste Priorität wir verwenden
gezielte Tötungen aus der Luft nur wenn
wir keine andere Wahl haben wir werden
es immer als letzten Ausweg nutzen um
unsere Bürger zu schützen
rund um die Uhr sind sie in der Luft die
Augen immer auf den Bildschirmen sie
dürfen keinen Fehler machen sonst
bringen sie ihre Kameraden am Boden oder
unschuldige Zivilisten in Gefahr
in diesem Video von 2021 sieht man das
Haus eines palästinensischen Terroristen
kommen durs im Gazastreifen kurz bevor
die israelische Luftwaffe angreift aber
es sind Kinder in der Nähe
die Touristen verstecken sich häufig in
Wohngebieten sogar direkt neben Schulen
und Kindergärten benutzen Unbeteiligte
als menschliche Schutzschilder
[Musik]
die Richtlinie wird immer sein die
kleinste Bombe einzusetzen um dir
erforderliche Leistung zu erbringen wir
verstehen das Luftangriffe auch ein
Risiko haben wir führen einen
Luftangriff durch nur wenn wir wissen
dass der Ort sterilis und es keine
Gefahr gibt das Unbeteiligte verletzt
werden
absolute Gewissheit gibt es nie das
wissen auch die Soldaten
eine große mentale Belastung fuhr die
terrorjäger
seit tausend führt die israelische Armee
gezielte Angriffe auf Terroristen durch
auslöser war die sogenannte zweite in
die förder eine Terrorwelle mit 460
Raketenangriffen
138 Selbstmord Anschlägen und über
13.000 Attentate mit Schusswaffen
fünf Jahre dauert Terror mit Uwe tausend
ermordeten und mehr als 7000 verletzte
Israelis
vor die israelische Politik sind die
gezielten totungen Notwehr mehrere
hunderte soll Israel in den vergangenen
23 Jahren durchgeführt haben die genaue
Zahl ist geheim
es begann kurz vor der zweiten in die
Fada aber sie müssen verstehen dass wir
es sehr sparsam verwenden oft entstehen
viele Schlagzeilen als würde der Staat
Israel ständig aus der Luft vernichten
die Zahl der Verhaftung ist um
Größenordnungen größer als die Zahl der
gezielten Tötungen die wirklich nur für
sehr einzigartige und boutiquefälle
vorbehalten sind und das ist wirklich
außergewöhnlich
[Musik]
verfolgt seine Feinde und erbittlich
Rückblick
München Olympische Spiele 1972 verüben
palästinensische Terroristen ein
Massaker an elf israelischen Sportlern
seit mehr als 20 Jahren verfolgt und
eliminiert Israel die Täter und
Drahtzieher des Olympia Attentats Zorn
Gottes heißt diese Operation
oder Iran das iranische Regime will
Israel mit Atomwaffen von der Landkarte
tilgen im November 2020 wird Mose
fakrise day Leiter der iranische
Atomprogramms in der Nähe von Teheran
getötet er wird erschossen als er in
seinen ungepanzerten Fahrzeug nach Hause
fährt mit ihm Wagen seine Frau am
Straßenrand stehen zwei präparierte
Fahrzeuge
ausgestattet mit ferngesteuerten Waffen
wir Satelliten werden diese ausgelöst
töten verkrise die unbemannte
totungsmaschine gesteuert aus der Ferne
heute
schnell heißt es der mossa der
israelische Auslandsgeheimdienst stecke
hinter diese Aktion Beweise dafür gibt
es nicht
es war ein System das funktionierte und
nur auf dem Motore abzählte der Zoom war
direkt auf seinem Gesicht seine Frau die
25 cm von ihm entfernt saß wurde in
keiner Weise verletzt
[Musik]
israelische Öffentlichkeit sieht
gezielte Tötungen als notwendiges Übel
an aber es heißt nicht dass sie keine
Fragen hat wenn was schief läuft
der durchschnittliche Israeli fordert
dass die Armee hohe Standards erfüllt
und dass wenn sie beschließt gegen
jemanden vorzugehen dies eine Person ist
die tatsächlich eine tickende oder
kontinuierliche Bombe ist oder dass sie
gezielt angegriffen wird um ein
Terroranschlag zu vermeiden
andererseits fordert der
durchschnittlich Israeli auch das
unschuldige Menschen nicht verletzt
werden und wenn das nicht passiert und
aus Versehen unschuldige verletzt werden
wie im Fall von Salach schade gibt es
viel öffentliche Kritik schade war einer
der Anführer der hamast der hinter den
schlimmsten Anschlägen in Israel steckte
als er getötet wurde kam eine ganze
Familie ums Leben weil sie sich im
Keller neben ihm versteckt hatte
zurück zu unserem Einsatz
investitionenland die Region ist dich
besiedelt 3 Millionen Menschen die
meisten
unbescholtene Bürger die ihre Arbeit
nachgehen
und andererseits Terroristen die sich
dort unter der Zivilbevölkerung
verstecken um Sie zu identifizieren
setzt die israelische Armee auch Frauen
ein
50 Prozent des Geheimdienst Personals
das in den Flugzeugen mitfliegt sind
Mädchen dies hat eine dramatische
Bedeutung in der Aufgabe am Ende da wir
als Team danach streben die Information
auszuschöpfen wenn eine weibliche
Aufklärerin dort sitzt denkt sie anders
als der Junge der neben ihr sitzt und
deshalb ist dies ein wichtiger Teil
unserer Informationsbeschaffung
die Pilotin mit der wir fliegen ist
Mutter von zwei Kindern auch einer der
beiden Aufklärer ist eine 20-jährige
Frau
ihr seid Teil verschiedene Missionen
manchmal auch Teil von gezielten
Tötungen ist das etwas dass sie
verunsichert oder etwas was man später
verarbeiten muss
wir sind hier vielen Dingen ausgesetzt
die haben operativen Ende passieren wir
kommen nicht drumherum wir sind in der
Armee und wir tun es so gut wie es
können und auf die edelste und
menschlichste Weise die wir kennen und
das hält uns geistig gesund weil wir
wissen dass wir auf der Seite der Wache
und es Beschützer stehen
nach Stunden in der Luft landen wir auf
der geheimen Luftwaffenbasis mitten in
Israel während des Flugzeug für den
nächsten Einsatz Staat klargemacht wird
bekommen wir Meldung über einen neuen
Terroranschlag in Jerusalem aufs Handy
sie werden längst beobachtet aus der
Luft
[Musik]